hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy and i'm
a licensed architect in
beautiful vancouver bc today's episode
is a part of a new series i'm starting
called
mundane mondays where i talk about the
more practical
the less sexy the slightly more
mundane aspects of the job that will
nevertheless make up a very big part of
your day-to-day as an architect
and are also aspects of the job that you
will probably
not learn about in school because
they don't want to scare you away
however these are
aspects of the job that i personally
enjoy very much
and are probably one of the aspects that
give me the most pride in being an
architect
[Music]
so i made a video a couple weeks ago
where i listed all the different
requirements that you need to become an
architect
including the amount of hours you need
to fill in certain categories
i got a question asking if i could
elaborate on the engineering systems
coordination
category but i felt like it would be
hard to give you
an explanation without giving you an
overview
of how we actually work with engineers
so in this video i'm going to give you a
brief description of what each of the
consultants do
and when and how to coordinate with them
and what your responsibilities are the
architect is usually responsible for the
selection design and coordination of
these building systems
including the engineering systems the
main ones are
structural mechanical electrical and
building envelope but that doesn't mean
that you have to know everything about
all of these systems
you just have to be familiar with the
performance and how it impacts the
overall function of the building the
engineers they're always there to help
you
so there's the structural engineers
they'll calculate things like
the typical bay framing maximum depth of
the members
minimum ceiling clearances they'll
coordinate items that
will have to be embedded into the
structures like light fixtures
conduits or junction boxes they'll
calculate requirements for fire ratings
they'll give you provisions
for special equipment and typical
mechanical equipment
they'll review the availability of
materials
and they'll also respond to defined
programming areas
mechanical engineers they're going to be
looking at things like
natural ventilation whether you want to
use a central
or individual heating systems the size
of the
ac and heating equipment special hvac
systems
wall and roof construction the
associated
r values energy analysis and modeling
glazing requirements and window
coverings room temperature and humidity
levels
they're going to be looking at the
approximate size of the mechanical
equipment
plumbing fixtures and controls water and
waste removal features like noise
control vibration dampers
any owner requirements or operations
requirements
and an energy management strategy for
electrical consultants
they're going to be looking at the
anticipated load
and allowances for future expansion
they're going to be looking at
requirements for incoming services and
space requirements for vaults or
substations
distribution of power and how much
voltage you're going to be using
location of electrical closets
communications rooms
bus duct risers requirements for
embedded circuits
light fixture selection requirements for
ceiling systems also selecting the light
fixtures
which will be a nice design aspect for
them switching controls for energy
efficiency
telecommunications and data systems fire
alarm systems
public address systems intercoms
sometimes
we could get a special lighting
consultant your responsibility is to
coordinate all these different systems
typically how that happens is
you send them your architectural
drawings and
after a couple of weeks they'll send you
their drawings that are based off of
your drawings
and you basically mark it up and redline
them
for any conflicts or if you have any
questions or concerns
you send that to them so i mentioned
earlier that it is not your job to know
everything about these systems
your job is really just to check for the
form
for example if you have an exposed
ceiling all the duct work
is going to be visible so did they pick
out the ones that
look nice that work with the rest of the
design
are they laid out in a nice way for
example if you look at the pompidou
center
the mechanical systems are a really
essential part of the
overall design of the building so
project like that
was done with very intentional
tight integration with the engineers
then you have to look out for the
location is it placed in a location that
works with the rest of the design
so for example when the electrical
engineer is putting together his
drawings
he's not aware of all the mechanical
ducts that are going into the space
so it's your job to see if there's any
conflicts if there's any
ducts running into the lights and make
note of that
and lastly you're not responsible for
any calculations
unless you're doing a passive house
building you might have to do the
calculations for that
but even that like you would typically
have an energy
and an envelope consultant the
consultants are responsible
and liable for making sure that the
systems they're proposing
works with the needs of the space
they're also responsible for making sure
that the systems that they're proposing
meet all the building code
and the other regulations actually
you're supposed to get this in writing
saying that they're going to be in
compliance with all the different codes
depending on the project engineers are
brought in at different phases of the
project
sometimes during schematic design
sometimes during design development
if they're brought in during schematic
design the architect would have already
determined
the spatial requirements the circulation
the massing the impact of the sun
or shade or snow or rain on the building
if the engineer is brought in during the
concept phase
it means that they're really helping you
develop
those structural mechanical electrical
concepts for the building
so if you have a really big cantilever
in your building it will be wise to
consult a structural engineer before you
move too far ahead with the design
because it'll have an impact on your
ceiling height
where those structural members have to
be which will
eventually have an impact on the design
so as you're designing you should work
with a structural engineer to
make sure that what you're designing is
feasible earlier you bring them on
the less work it could be down the road
and they could also help you reduce the
construction costs
but if it's a pretty simple project then
it's not really worth
getting the client to pay for another
consultant
so early on so it's really dependent on
the project
sometimes the engineers are brought on
even before the schematic design phase
in the feasibility phase where
the client is trying to get an
understanding of
how much the project is going to cost
to see if it's even worth starting the
project i was on a project
where we were designing a canopy in a
site near a ravine and it was on a very
steep slope
and so we got the structural engineer
involved very very early on in the
project
and he was able to tell us what kind of
system we needed to use for a site like
this
using this we were able to get an
estimate for the cost
actually ended up being a little bit too
expensive for the client so
we actually unfortunately didn't end up
moving forward with the project but
that's a much better scenario than doing
all this work
and then later on getting them involved
and
later on finding out that it's too
expensive to build
because the client would have already
spent all this money on your fees
so your job as the architect and the
consultant
is to help the client get an
understanding
of how much it's going to cost and the
feasibility of the project
the next stage is design development and
so you continue having the meetings that
you've been having
or in some projects the engineers could
be brought on
at this stage and you just continue
collecting information from the clients
and the consultants
this is typically where you would start
doing your
coordination because this is probably
when you would put in your building
permit
and to put in a building permit you need
a
written confirmation from all these
consultants saying that yes
i have designed in a way that abides to
the regulation
and code of the jurisdiction and then in
the construction document stage you
continue to check and review the
consultant's drawings
but in much much much more detail than
in the previous phase
this is also when you would prepare your
final specs
for all the different systems the
lighting
fixtures you would know exactly which
lighting fixture you're gonna get if you
have
a error handling unit then
the mechanical engineers supposed to
specify exactly
what brand what size we're going to be
getting on the project you would also do
a more detailed cost estimate for this
phase
it's a lot of revising and reviewing
drawings
and you would also at the end of the
phase typically submit it
to the client for review and then
there's the bidding and negotiations
phase
in most projects where the contractors
they bid
on the project you would start this
phase with a
site meeting where you invite
all the people who are going to be
bidding on the project
and sometimes even the consultants come
on board
and you'd describe all the details of
the job it gives the contractors an
opportunity to
ask questions before they submit a bid
this is when you review shop drawings
which are drawings that the manufacturer
will have of a specific product
contractors might suggest
an alternative product to the product
that you had specified
so if there is a um
i don't know special ceiling that you
wanted to use but it's not
available in vancouver bc
then the contractor would ask for an
alternate
and ask oh can we use this very similar
other product that's from l.a so you
compare the two
products and you let them know if that's
okay or not
and then the next phase is the
construction phase also known as the
construction
admin phase during this time you're
going to cite regularly checking upon
the progress of the job
you're putting together reports to send
to the client
and you're basically going there making
sure that everything has been
built to the way that you had drawn it
and specified it
there's a lot of paperwork involved if
the contractor
wants to change one little detail they
have to send you
a written notice sometimes even with the
drawings
asking if it would be okay to do that
especially if it's gonna
add cost to the project then that's
another process
so yeah there's a lot of paperwork
during this phase
but it's also a very fun
aspect of the job because every week
every two weeks you
are seeing this thing that you had drawn
up
get built in real life and then
typically at the end of the month
there's this thing called a progress
claim where the contractor basically
lists all the progress they've made
like oh we put in the glazing oh we put
in the floor
and then they'll say okay like we
completed uh
80 of the job so can you pay us for this
much
and so you are supposed to
review their progress on site and you're
supposed to recommend to the client
um okay like it's actually true it's
been done to 80 and then the client can
pay the contractor and so this is the
same with the consultants
you send the progress claims to the
electrical consultant or the mechanical
consultant
and then they'll be able to tell the
client
whether the progress is what they really
say
it is and then the last phase is the
project closeout
or the project takeover and then in this
phase you do a final walkthrough
make sure there's no deficiencies make
sure there's no scratches on the walls
in that case the client can
withhold payment from the contractor so
that
they're forced to finish the job and
then you will have to prepare
record drawings if uh it was a part of
your contract
well that was a really long video but i
hope you guys found that
information helpful and i hope that you
guys got a little sense
of what coordination is
and what this part of the job is like
if you found this video helpful please
give me a thumbs up and if you haven't
already
subscribe and check out my other videos
i have some other
interesting videos that are not as dry
as this
you